[Laughter]
hey george i'm gonna go get some food
can you just add bobby to the game and
invite him and i'm like i came back
why haven't you done it yeah he's like
he won't accept my friend request
oh it's so funny because the other night
the other night friday yeah me
my brother and dylan yeah we won
our first trio trio not nighttime
regular
oh it's and the last person standing was
me how many kills
i got six that game right but i um
but the way i did it right so dylan was
up against two guys
right in the last circle final circle
yeah and dylan is going
uphill and he's shooting and one of he
kills one guy but the other guy
downs them and the smoke is coming in
all right
as i see that i'm going around this
ledge because i know that the other guy
is going to go
toward the the you know the line to go
to the other circle yeah
but i knew what direction it was going
so i went around the cliff
like it wasn't out of nerves it wasn't
out of nerves it wasn't out of like
i'm guessing i it was an instinctual i
know right and as soon as i turn the
corner
his back is to me boom and i and i wipe
him out
we get the win i scream i was gonna ask
what was the celebration
at first i go team wipe because i
thought that trying to stay cool
no no i thought that there was another
team oh there's no way
you know there's a last game no there's
no way that's the last guy
i just go team wide so i'm going to die
eventually
right and as soon as i say team white
right and i go
like that okay we're steven dylan
freaking out oh we're all like
our veins are popping out of our heads
it's our first one right it's not easy
to do folks yeah
but if you're if you do that right and
you record it because we did record it i
haven't
i have proof right let's post it don't
ever show it to kalyla because she's not
into it
i went to the i went to work's bedside
well no no no no
i was like literally on the toilet so
she was kidding
barged in you barged him because
for his first he tried
he's you know from outside the door he's
like babe something magical just
happened oh
magical she's probably like oh my god
what happened what happened
and i was like don't come in don't come
in something i have to i have to show
you what happened
yeah yeah and he comes in and he's like
this in tears he's like
i was crying yeah and then you
imagine it wasn't because i've won
before
i understand because i know who you've
played with before in this team
i understand why it was a special moment
i get it yeah because steve is getting
better
my brother's getting better but my
brother's more um face-to-face
murderer yeah yeah my my brother's not
good at like um
out in the open my brother's good at
like
hiding in a corner or or being back
backup he's very good
and he's very instinctual he's he's very
good player right
dylan is very good and then sometimes
not good
right i don't know what kind of player i
am right
i would say i'm same as a combination
between the two
right but as a team you know i've played
with the best guys
you really have the best guys josh is a
[ __ ] beast
semi-pro folks yeah he's like he used to
be pro right
so when i went with those guys it's like
oh i didn't kill anybody i'm just
i'm like you know what i am i'm like um
um
saving private ryan um henry what's his
name's
character you know the guy that was e.t
oh oh right he was the translator
oh you're the yeah i'm that guy you're
talking to the other people yeah yeah
yeah like i'm
not yeah yeah i'm not really wait wasn't
he also
samuel in um the legends of the fall
remember when he gets stuck there's
smoke and then he gets stuck
in the barbed wire and then brad pitt's
running towards him and he's like samuel
samuel i don't know and he's like
tristan
he's in the house of haunted hill house
and wait can you
make sure i'm not losing my mind legend
of the fall samuel
samuel what's his name i don't think i
think it says aidan quinn you're saying
adam quinn's other brother doug hughes
henry thomas henry thomas
you're right it is samuel so henry
thomas is his name henry thomas was in
um
e.t yeah he's a legend but um
so i'm usually like that but with the
two guys we've only taken second before
a couple times right
and so for us to win one and for me to
be the last one standing
kind of the leader yeah it's it's a
feeling of any
to delay person to the lay person who's
not not just a lay person a person in
the bathroom
pooing no an uninterested don't ever
give a [ __ ]
yeah i'm not a warrior victory lay
person
i know a lay person it's a clay person
it's beyond that i know it's beyond it
but let's just okay let's just like i
my mom would have more interest
i know but like um
i don't argue with you but um i
understand it's a joy of yours and i
accept it
i just don't really want to celebrate
with you because i don't know what i'm
celebrating
i showed you the video yeah exactly i
don't think i know and i'm like what did
i do i said good job babe
yeah but there's no feeling behind it
it's like what did you want me to do
[ __ ] blow you in that moment no no
that could have been that's extreme but
that would have been nice
it's extreme but nice but no but how
about a little just bit a little beyond
like
understanding of what that entails how
many people fly into the world
uh 250 to 200 all right so you're
talking about
a guy right here convince her to care
this is great i'm just trying to come to
you
yeah i want to try to convince you i
know everything that goes down in war
zone and i've tried to care and i've
i've taken measures to sit and
and then he has to sit there and watch
his teammates play i get it
and then now he has to win the gulag i
get all of it
i get the smoke at the very end i know
what it looks i know what a victory
looks like
i i just i i'm sorry i i'm
i have no [ __ ] to give you i know she's
well-read
but can i just try to convince you here
for a second here
just give me enough you know what i do
respect i do respect the joy that you
feel and i believe it's
real real joy that you feel i just don't
know how to feel it with you
that's true but um let's suppose not you
but let's suppose
i was in a relationship with a woman
okay the gap tooth okay like a woman
that like did something
that i didn't totally understand like
she she
she's in a competition of making
um skyscrapers with popsicle sticks
i love popsicle sticks very quick so
let's say i had a girlfriend
who that's all she did 12 hours a day
her deal is to make you know
skyscrapers and buildings and unique
unique architecture
with popsicle sticks in real life or in
a video game no in real life and she
goes to a place
right and every week right there's 150
kids
i love it or people that do it right and
she just started
she doesn't even know how it works and
all these kids have been doing it for 10
15 years
right they're pros right they know how
to do build
right and this kid you know i mean it's
like how does it how do you even get
two together and it's just learning the
dynamics of it right
and then five months later right
that my girlfriend comes home and goes i
won
the whole thing i beat all these pros
and these people that have been doing it
for [ __ ] she's
crying she's crying i think that i
wouldn't
in my heart couldn't say i didn't give a
[ __ ]
can i just defend myself i don't think
i'm just like
let me finish right you have a rubbish i
don't think that i could do that i could
you know i would have to do everything i
could to jump into their joy
right and to understand right fully
understand
what they're talking about do i think
it's ridiculous making
popsicle sticks buildings i don't give a
[ __ ] right
i think it's ridiculous but she enjoys
it
and she um she's dedicated to work this
is
pure unadulterated manipulation
uh colloquia colloquiality it's like
like one of those things where it's like
he has to defend his sedentary lifestyle
and the fact that he's 50 years old and
a real greedy
dreaming about a win that does not
affect reality in any way shape or form
it might have a blip
in his dopamine level but that's about
all that happens
there is no effect net effect in the
world there's no net effect
on our relationship there's no net
effect in his career
in his finances yeah but how does
popsicle sticks have a net effect
what i'm saying is that she's inspired
other kids like really like
she's that's a art and i'm inspiring
other kids
kids could do what you just did not all
of them okay
not to say that i'm not happy i said i
respect the joy that you feel
yeah yeah but you can't be resentful
that i don't understand what that joy
feels like
because there's there and i i know you
beyond just congratulations babe good
job i can't give you more than that
that's fine
okay i'm just saying that if you made
popsicle stick buildings
i would give you more that's all
possible
i'm going to talk about my victories in
my life okay go ahead right yeah
you have not celebrated not a single one
in fact last year you walked out halfway
through them singing me happy birthday
whoa baby why are you thinking this is
the comedy
and that's what we call the dagger
that's so funny how we went from like
that was a joy of mine i know but you
didn't care i understand that you know
she just said she went the lannister
pace her death
why did you have to go down there
right it's like we're having tit-for-tat
fun
right and then you had to bring out the
[ __ ] katana yeah and
finish him it's like not because i don't
start a fight finishing move for sure
okay it's not a real thing
i want you to name three joys and
accomplishments
that i've been that that meant a lot to
me that you've celebrated in
take your time your birthday boom that's
not an accomplishment
one bite you made it and also you walked
away
halfway through it you know one point
you know i just want a little bit of
you know a little bit of joy when it
comes to my
war zone victory i want to know what
that sounds like what what should have i
done
like what what besides like oh that's
really cool we play it
replay it well you shouldn't have said
this this is what you said
yeah um is it long because we started
playing
because i started playing it you're like
when is it over get to the thing
i remember having to fast forward it to
just the very end
right yeah so maybe that maybe you know
what that's it you should have watched
the whole game watch the whole 10
minutes the whole 10-minute gameplay
you know what that is good practice
though like if we ever want children
down the road i have to be really into
hey mom what they show me
yeah i'm a child in that way you know
and you know i'm never going to win
again with those two
i'll win again with gilbert or something
from georgia maybe but not you have to
understand
the group with those two that grouping
right
in terms of the way they play and it's
just it was a fluke and it was
an anomaly and it for some reason
the universe and it was just a cool
moment in time you know
do i feel depressed that yeah i feel
depressed that
that those are some of the joys that
give me you know me that feeling
that doesn't that doesn't make sense but
you don't have to
you know how can you feel depressed
about a joy
that that just means it's three points
three four three points
three points for a couple that means
it's not a true joy it's a guilty
pleasure
and there isn't a certain like a level
of guilt that you that you hold inside
whatever you know what i already i i'm
do i not let you
have your you do what a great person
thank you
it's wonderful um i've also been we've
been also watching
uh have we talked about the british bake
off let's talk about it but um i'm
trying to get my brother to watch it
he's not gonna watch it but he refuses
to want it right